this podcast is brought to you by vince
arrow watches tired of choosing between
luxury styling and high-end quality and
an affordable price tag when sara
watches wants to help you with
timepieces that expertly blend style
timing and class with a price tag
you've never expected a watch built this
well guys when this watch arrived I was
blown away with the quality check out
our shots Luis this is beautiful there
you understand me do me a favor you're
not just getting a watch elevate your
game elevate your watch game whenever
Sarah watch go to check out Vince Vince
arrow I get the watch net right now even
better then Sarah was given all church
listeners 15% off their entire purchase
with the promo code Church and check out
it's time to step up your watch game go
to Vince arrow and get the watch dotnet
how you like me now number two let me
tell you something you go to Vegas you
gonna Lennox Ellie it's a blast
you get chlamydia the whole thing but
personally I'm a big fan or you know
poker blackjack I like to watch people
play dice sometimes I win sometimes I
lose not so good but I always gave a
good time the problem is getting to
Vegas isn't that easy for me you know
I'm saying I'm a fat [ __ ] woman the roll
escape back and forth but ever since I
found my B casino betting from the
comfort of my home has been simple and a
[ __ ] blast that's why I always tell
people to go to my B casino dot AG they
got huge bonuses free spins and much
more so off the bat you're already
winning from the day you create your
account do me a favor right join my B
casino and deposit Ella to triple your
bankroll with their amazing 200% signup
bonus use promo code Church 200 to
activate your offer beat the house from
your house you understand me you said
your living room you got your underwear
on you know your socks your scratching
your nuts
you got a sudden urge to gamble playa my
be casino dot AG today and use code
Church 200
right now you're sitting there [ __ ]
bored again you play you win you get
paid Lee kick that [ __ ] mule
and go for being what the [ __ ]
finally my brothers yes the best looking
twins on the business yeah
Cory and Chad welcome to the show you
guys hit me up a few months ago and I'm
my kind of [ __ ] am I gonna figure it out
I get the [ __ ] [ __ ] on the
show you know this ain't no uh who's
your father type show yeah hold on one
second we found your father
yeah find him tell me else's mother when
we [ __ ] up and get different fathers
Cory you always cut your Cory's father
but not chance my yeah and we got the
Christ killer fresh from hanging out
three days with his dad always a good
deed you deposit a coin in a karmic camp
Karma Bank when you do that type of [ __ ]
it seems like a six miles out of your
pocket but in reality your again to
spend time with your dad a lot of people
don't have that that privilege so that's
why I always urge people you have time
to [ __ ] if your dad's all go down
there pick his brain write a book yeah
the guy's sitting there dying to talk to
somebody new you're [ __ ] around with
your friends at Starbucks and the most
interesting person in your life is sit
on a couch by himself with a diaper and
some Nicaraguan Shake chase his [ __ ]
diaper go down there yeah get him a
chick get him a [ __ ] you know say
maybe a good son but imagine being like
18 your son bring your chick the suck it
dick wasn't 24 I instantly get it I
would just look at your son and going I
love you yeah I always knew last night I
and I'm very sorry for doing this I put
up a show and I told people is my 53rd
birthday so people have been confused
for three days the reason I had that
show at the Ice House last night because
it was Ralphie Mae's birthday and I
wanted to celebrate Ralphie May but I
didn't want to put it out there and have
people show up with tears and comics
that you know don't know nothing about
nothing so the first person people I
thought it was Cory and Chad because I
wanted to give you a different
perspective the professional comedian
I know what Ralphy meant that he's too
[ __ ] guys these two guys would take a
bullet for Ralphie you know look what
happened in Florida god bless these kids
all those three teachers that were shot
I got for those kids hi new teachers
like that yeah and I know who are my
friends that would do that learn saying
I mean who would [ __ ] grab me and
turn around
last week my daughter was the park and
she was with a girl and she ran the girl
found my daughter kept playing I can go
ahead and grab my go listen go back and
she's the one play I'm gonna go back to
your friend lesson number one in the
life with your friends always go back
for your fraf to go back if he's getting
the beating of his life Jumpman if he's
getting arrested at least let's figure
out how to get him out already
yeah with no drama but without a pinch
right I'm saying let's figure out how to
[ __ ] if it's murder let's figure out
how to sabotage the car yeah and if it's
license plate something stupid let's go
somewhere we got bail ready to go by the
time he gets to court we're already in
there
with the $50 bail guy and I'm saying
whatever always go back for your friends
and it's so weird in this business we
have acquaintances mmm we have friends
and then we have brothers and then we
have mentors yeah and I think Ralphie
was that to both of us
oh yeah as as older as I was a lot older
than Ralphie May but I learned many
things from him you know you have a
privilege in your life you got to learn
from one of the best you got to go on
the road with one of the best and so did
I yeah I got to go on the road with Joe
Rogan the education is invaluable right
you know tell us from day one how this
relationship started
we met Ralph talking to them like dogs
oh yeah we we met Ralph at the Hollywood
improv we were sleeping on the streets
to do Last Comic Standing and we met him
but we didn't really talk to him and he
walked by us and asked us what we're
doing it was like four days before we
wanted to be number one in line so he
goes hey [ __ ] that someone hold your
place come in and do time don't be out
here in the cold and he put us on his
show and yeah he which we needed he
critiqued us and basically told us we
weren't ready for that show and and
which was the best advice because we
weren't ready for that show we still
slept on the streets and still found out
we weren't ready for it but now it
started from there yeah and he educated
us right from that point and then next
time he came in to Brea or maybe Ontario
or improv here in Southern California we
got to open up for him and then that
relationship got built to where fast
forward just two three years and then we
were on the road with them full-time
full-time yeah you know living with him
on the bus and you were there well he
was selling off theaters oh we would do
theaters we do you know Boston that
Wilber that big son of a [ __ ] we would
be there do several show I'm you know
lucky the paps theater all the big giant
like historic theaters that you know
more than just a two three four thousand
seats and then Ralph would sell them out
and you know the whole deal merch and we
learned everything you know from them
the business side of it not just tell
dick jokes and you know something
underlined when you went up in front of
his crowd a few times did you guys Bob
yeah one time I'll tell you I mean if a
few but one time in Vegas we're smoking
and then he we got cocky and he's like
you better get a stand he would always
tell us this thing STS he was go out
there and steal the show they paid to
see me but they're gonna leave Smash
Brothers fans go out there and STS
that's all you ever had to tell us so we
were cocky were like we're gonna get one
[ __ ] so we went out there and we
ate a dick oh and he didn't light us he
did it on purpose and he kept watching
and he kept watching it and the [ __ ]
light I'm like where's the light and
where's the light he looked at us and he
just flipped us off he's like [ __ ]
okay and southern warning we took his
hand he go where'd you lose him and he
stopped and at a conversation in front
of a crowd that's not laughing no more I
wanted to know what we did wrong and
then he goes go to the side you have
another show you're making up we what
would you rather do even that of another
edible or go through that I totally
listen to him calmly now for about he
started about a year ago but the last
three weeks he's [ __ ] getting into it
right and he's been doing great I mean
he's a great he's a Woody Allen type
he's like Woody Allen he's what they're
neurotic the Jew comes out but not
really right which is really cool and so
when they were sitting here smoking pot
I'm getting them a high and you know
right now everything's blood you know
everything's Rose it's a honeymoon
period way you know yeah I'm his buddy
he's friends all comics and when they
see him they give love you know right so
I said to him you know Lee I gotta talk
to you pretty soon I gotta start
torturing you on stage yeah what are you
talking about like co-op Ted tell you to
do ten and you already got your time
you've been working hard for ten you've
been saying oh you know I got seven and
three-quarters if I improvise and after
you up there for [ __ ] 10 minutes I'm
not giving you a light and you're
looking at me going and I'm like three
you've only done three minutes yeah at
least phrase got ready and then I go
after a while just give you the finger
like just [ __ ] you yeah because I'm
Matt's how you become a comic it really
is but this is just it's craziness that
you added this leap say that I miss a
beat I told you what we do to you
I can't even imagine not happening we're
talking in front of like oh 1500 I don't
know how many people a [ __ ] lot and
then he's just laughing fighting it out
you're fighting it out your face is red
you're gonna feel sweat come out from
places where you've never even thought
you had a sweat gland
like after the show the back easy why I
told you after Austin I had to wait tell
you've done cap city right yeah you know
right off the stage like there's a
little seating area and then like
there's a wall yeah he I went on the
last show I did I think five minutes and
I was fine on stage but when I got off I
had to leave
against the wall for 10min I couldn't
walk back my legs were shaking levels I
mean it's because we have to get you
used to being there like there's nothing
like for the beginner comic to really
understand the patois of the bomb mm-hmm
but all of the bomb is your first two
jokes they kind of get it and after that
it's a long night but guess what the
emcee decided to get his dick sucked so
he's not giving you the light and you're
there coming up you you're stealing yeah
any comic that tells you hasn't stole at
that point they're alive like a
[ __ ] you spilling knock-knock
joke whatever this without you oh my god
sue karappa and some new koi yeah like
at the nine-minute mark to make it even
worse that's Chris Rock's junkie you
know and it's not the bomb I want you to
feel what the emotion feels like yeah
and except silence he would always say
silence is okay
that means they're listening hero is
tell us that you don't be in a rush to
get to the next one he so smile take a
sip whatever don't he would always tell
us that cuz he felt like he was the king
of that
yeah he was the king of that well he did
like two hours at every Nam we've seen
him do we did in an hour and he did
three and a half and Addison improv it
was a foreign half hour show that and
this guy in the front row was so into
Ralphie that he actually passed out fell
under the [ __ ] stage was seizure in
and [ __ ] and then Ralphie stopped the
show help them soon as the guy got
carried out Ralphie kept going and we
did he did three nine [ __ ] hours that
night think about that three now [ __ ]
hour that's a long time and people
weren't leaving
you know people stop there we go in like
2000
eight I started having doubts guys yeah
mental health is a big is a thin line in
this business mental health comedy and
art and I didn't invent that Rudy Sarzo
said it to me one time
I always know it existed right I started
a small you know I started in Denver
than the Seattle comedy scene yeah she
self why are these people keep throwing
up every week but guess what that's a
thing right you know that dead goal
isn't our goal you know so it's
different mental health that's me mm I
moved to the valley in 2009 there's a
Ford dealership down the corner well and
I said to myself Oh Quinton
I'm not quit this [ __ ] I'm gonna do
stand-up around the area get movies for
my friends audition me or whatever
that's for like four months I didn't say
nothing and I would go see headliners
and bran and urban without saying a word
I would want two of the guys who
recognized me that time and I opened for
Jo and I would headline on Wednesdays
and Sunday like you guys yeah exactly
and I went to see every headline on out
there that year and I saw some [ __ ]
horror shows watch what kept me in the
game but the two best acts I saw that
year were Greg Geraldo and Ralphie May
and that's as buy at spun by like
Ralphie May in 2009 was [ __ ]
untouchable yeah the style the breathing
the the charisma the whole [ __ ]
package how he sold merch at the end on
stage with the no money that that I it
was guys you know a lot of people have
seen Ralphie they're listening but it
was something that I went home and I was
like there was three times I almost
doubted myself economy saw Doug Stanhope
in 2006 in Seattle you have no idea guys
yeah I went home and cried
I was like I'm done I'm done I'm never
gonna do comedy again cuz I'll never be
that good now you said to yourself
you'll never be that good and then I saw
Ralphie and Gregg around on 2009 it was
like I don't know it's it's funny he
said that we've had that same talk that
you just said like with each other and I
we were watching Ralphie crush and he
was singing he made up some improv [ __ ]
he was singing in and he got standing
ovations like 40 minutes into his set
and it wasn't he wasn't even [ __ ]
closing but he's crushing so hard they
just [ __ ] stand up you know then he
would close with that Bon Jovi you know
I need [ __ ] in the crowd we're
talking thousands of people will be
singing with him and he'd just be
smiling and like you said he'd get off
and two hours he'd stand out there and
shake everybody's hand and now everyone
does that a lot of guys just go to the
[ __ ] green room go [ __ ] [ __ ] and
then they're on to the next town he
would stand out there and then he would
ask him where we going where's everybody
going where's the spot and then we go
till 2:00 in the morning whatever town
we were in and he'd stay out cuz he
loved his [ __ ] fans he loved the
people and we learned a lot from him
like that just amazed like I can't
believe he rocked it like that hard well
I've it was like what I learned from him
was how to be a gentleman yeah well he
was a lot younger than I was and in 98
97 I was still untamable like I was
still at the table the cocaine was
burning deep in my soul yeah and I meet
this young southern fat
warm kid that man he was a scared kid
guys everybody was sir ma'am you know I
mean it was really amazing and then the
reefer and then he was off and running
yeah
and he knew day one what he was gonna do
and now he was gonna do it huh you know
he knew day one he was struggled for a
couple months or a year and a half
Larry David took about to lunch and
before the show it was there was a lot
of things that that's the Last Comic
Standing it was [ __ ] off and running
yeah yeah he told us after because
that's when we started working with them
and but full-time like around the time
you're saying two thousand eight nine
and that's when we started picking up
more and more gigs with them to where by
2009 and going into ten it was
full-blown just this guy works so much
to he pick up [ __ ] gigs on Tuesday
when most guys are hanging out we'd be
in Minnesota and snow and and the bus
would be there but we'd still he'd do a
[ __ ] show cuz we were just there like
he worked every day and we wouldn't post
about a lot of [ __ ] you know he would
just go do the show whoever was there
was there and just to stay busy cuz he
loved it you know he would really loved
it loved it like he would love it and
then we talked about because he didn't
write jokes you know we would just talk
on the bus he'd break our balls and then
run [ __ ] bias and he'd do it that night
and we talked about it to the next town
because he wouldn't remember half the
she does so much time you wouldn't
remember and that's what we would do
like John Madden we'd go over our sets
every [ __ ] night anyway whatever you
closed with your opening with that
tomorrow and I don't care what you close
with but you know he would challenge us
every night and he'd come up with topics
I was the other thing he busted our
balls he's like tonight everyone's gonna
do a joke on [ __ ] antelopes so and
I'm like antelopes
yeah whatever whatever he said he said
but he would [ __ ] with us and if you
didn't do it you're not getting the
light he would just look at your smile
you'd be like [ __ ] you you say what I
told you that you'd be out there second
have balls you know there's a reason
yeah and it's tough to explain to people
I worked for again
94/95 I work for a sports betting
service but guys the kind I was a genius
you look at people in your way and you
see what they have and the time they did
it how they did and how they started
that's what interests me that journey
mmm this cat was a winner
she was so good at what he did that you
know we were salesmen we sold us a
gambling information but he was so good
at what he did that by listening to what
you were saying he knew what was going
on and he'd come right over to you go
and he'd say the words eat other words
sometimes he'd take the fall in higher
your hand and impersonate you and say
the words and the words were so horrific
but if you said those words you got the
sale oh and when you didn't say him he
just hang up the phone and go you
already blew it
now on to the next one next time you're
free you just lost 15 miles give me this
lead and he just take money out of your
pocket there was no [ __ ] around and
you learned to listen which is the most
important thing in the [ __ ] world
especially with genomics we want to talk
we don't want to listen I just learned
to listen 6 years ago my life changed
right your life changes Ralphie was a
[ __ ] genius like Rogen myself playing
next to Rogen it's just me and him
and we break down comedy and we talked
about the different exercises that we
personally do all cuz we each have
quirks as comics you know tomorrow night
I'm gonna open up my closet oh Jesus
that's dangerous you know Jesus how do
you say that to somebody
yeah how do you say that but that's what
you force yourself to do as a man you go
tonight it's Thursday night it's my
opening night in Minnesota yeah I got
Friday and Saturday to redeem myself
yeah that's the mentality better luck so
that joke that you've been working on so
hard and they've been ripping and
Rocking guess what Lee you open up with
that [ __ ] today oh and that's
the night when I tell you to open up
with it and then I stretch the light on
you
like you're up there 45 drenched in
sweat puddles are coming out from under
you your update going on Jesus hmm
you're making noises and that's when you
walk off that stage you learn more about
yourself yeah who knows 30 minutes then
any psychiatrist psychological exam you
learn more by yourself and your ability
than anything in the world
yeah like I'm not a weird place where
like almost every time I go up it's a
regular record time one is for me I'm
like I did 1144 tonight so I can't and
then I only have like two jokes at best
so I can't imagine someone be like tell
a joke on pillows tonight and then you
just got to right there right up joke
that's gonna make people laugh ten
minutes yeah in ten minutes so you get
that a correlate right and I say to you
Lee
let's [ __ ] with you tonight both of us
it's Wednesday night exactly squat then
do 20 on pillows yeah just on pillows 20
minutes 20 minutes right there on the
spot yeah you got a look at me and go I
can't do that
Lee you're [ __ ] fine if you don't you
have to go do you have to go do it or
you're not going to Minneapolis next
week give it to [ __ ] D'Agostino but
you will walk off there feeling bullied
but you'll understand why I bullied a
hundred percent you'll go this
[ __ ] I'm never I'm not working
with this guy no more but you get to
look forward to we would laugh sometimes
I go then you get cocky
oh is that it and then you'd [ __ ] with
him hey you need to go up there and
whatever we he's heckled us from the
side of the stage and he starts yelling
at you yeah me too he taught you throw
out your punchline before we even got
the special in the bit and he's all go
like keep it on [ __ ] I opened
for him in Beaumont well I mean it was
that stop that's his he made us better
Lee I would go up on stage and he would
go cow cow do the tampon the string
[ __ ]
you know and you like that why don't you
tell him it Ralphie yeah [ __ ] he
would do that to us all the time you
just be hoping to god someone pulled the
fire alarm cuz you don't even want to
finish the [ __ ] but then before he'd
go onstage I never forget
for four years ever ever all right there
used to be do you know the Houston
improv is today yes before that you know
where was young years ago yeah at that
place that used to be a club called
Spellbinders back in the day don't know
I don't know if you know this story no
you're not laughing so you don't know no
I don't know Ralphie had been doing
comedy at the 9-year level or something
like this this was a big club in Houston
it was Spellbinders and a laptop or
something yeah you loved him and Ralphie
was a spellbinding this and he went
through the stage yes yes he didn't so
he went through the stage sued the club
right yeah
so the lady's name was I forget you know
I'm high I got forget guys so one day a
summer agreement how hard is it forget
the spell by this and they go it's she's
okay I go maybe I'm asking Ralphie me
yeah don't ask all tell him cuz Ralphie
went to the state he sued so one night
after one of those ball busting on stage
in Beaumont yeah
I get off stage and he's about you know
the host is up there one of these hosts
I think it was one that was host I was
the old comedy club in Beaumont that was
old owned by a beautiful black family
that worked the club there wasn't one he
was an engineer
she was like a rocket scientist and they
quit their job to open up a comedy club
in Beaumont Texas it's unheard of Wow
and they were black which to town next
to Beaumont they hang Jews blacks Cubans
I happened to buy blow there cuz I
showed up with a ball with three Ben
Franklin I'm saying they looked at the
three hundreds and said okay Diaz March
your way out of here you have Gooden the
long as yard though brother yeah
so I get offstage after he's heckling me
I'll do the [ __ ] joke do the ton of
Mia's joke you know like he's just
saying [ __ ] random and I'm laughing I'm
hi-yah I'm not the type of person that
would be mad because I know where his
love this oh absolutely
so I can always stage I Drive my in
those days I used to sweat a lot from
the blow the night before I'd be like a
skunk of there like I just [ __ ] and I
get off and I can I look at him this one
bite like a Ralphie by the way he goes
cow cow I'm gonna kill him that was a
great job by you Coco you killed him oh
by the way I forgot the tag the chick
from Spellbinders called
and she wants to book you in two weeks
right his face just froze yeah because
it was one of those things either
there's one nobody died yeah
and also he liked them he's like [ __ ]
you calculus went up there and lit that
room on fire then afterward he asked me
how did you find out about that yeah so
every three months I would drill him
with that right like I would drill him
with that listen bro it's a story you
want me to put a chick and then they
open up the improv and I would ask him
about the improbable find out that you
went through the stage there one time oh
yeah this one out for years you know
ready you want it to the [ __ ] states
this is in his early days finally he was
like six yeah he's big he's a big guy
and stuff yeah I remember when you know
and he has weight fluctuated he
shattered a few stools and we had to get
a stool we actually have one may not I
actually have it now I got hold of it
after he passed away but we actually had
a building had a steel stool made for
him so he could be comfortable on stage
you know and that's funny that he
[ __ ] fell through the [ __ ] stage I
lost it if I said bro he stood how to
make sure he's okay about a [ __ ] lost
it out man you know I was there for a
lot of the major good falls like did he
have any falls of you oh yeah in the
snow I mean come on one time he stepped
off the top step I was getting out of
the bus he stepped off the top step and
smushed me into the [ __ ] snowbank
there he just laid there in the [ __ ]
snow and they were just laughing
they're both laughing I'm like [ __ ] that
was like a [ __ ] hurt ah frigerator
Perry [ __ ] hit me why did you be
talking to a heavenly conversation than
the conversation and then he'd fall oh
yeah
yeah I'm a a listen one time one time
we're talking oh right we're at Penn
State we did a college show and we went
we're drinking dollar beers at the
whatever the [ __ ] bar when the kids
go he's talking to these girls and I
swear to god he's standing on the front
step he's talking to these girls he's
hanging on to the bars and [ __ ] and he
goes to clap his hands and laugh and
leave his balance it eats place is right
in the [ __ ] right on the ground I
nobody helped them I just like them I go
get up [ __ ] you [ __ ] you and I go get up
big boy he gets up and we just died
laughing oh yeah he would eat [ __ ] he
loved that fireball he'd drink too much
fireball you know push his [ __ ]
hassle I always tell him anything glass
take it from him cause he'd break he'd
drop a bomb shattering all over the
floor he's off god damn it Dave pull
this bus over we need to get a bong
immediately like you're just gonna pull
on bong stars and middle New Mexico my
god it was uh you know I was flat broke
and I'm watching this kid making
millions in front of me I know and every
Monday he called me and he go hopping on
the plane right now I'll be in LAX in
three I'll be in front of your door 5:30
and he would pick me up at 7:45 yeah of
course I'm downstairs that's it I go
that was two hours ago yeah I got tied
up yeah like something happen right that
much rope and he [ __ ] get in the car
we go to push Mart and he go in the back
seat he'd have him a little envelope
with 20s and I'd just roll and he'd take
a whole stack out taking the upstairs by
6 pounds of wheat and then give me the
leftover cash you know yeah I would just
die he knew I was doing blow he knew
what was going on he just didn't you
know
his generosity when he had money was
I never took advantage of them and I've
asked them for anything I've asked them
to go on the road he was my friend and I
had several conversations with him when
I told him I just want you to be my
friend cuz he was such a valuable ally
to me yeah he was different than
anything I had ever you know anybody I
had ever been around before I hung out
with people with good arts yeah I know
what a good-hearted guy was and and he
was one of those guys you know there was
a lot of people took advantage oh oh
yeah I still to this day don't [ __ ]
dig because he took care everybody even
when he was poor I know that you know
that know their people
when he was poor well he lives in an
apartment he was hustling between gigs
he was still taking care of people yeah
cooking for people cooking called
[ __ ] gardener you know he was just
taking care of people you know [ __ ]
gardener I was there to make that
[ __ ] deep fry the turkey I've
never even heard of that [ __ ] 36 in the
morning about the guard deep-frying a
[ __ ] turkey with six comedians over
there [ __ ] drinking yeah Jay Mohr I
mean Oh Gemma was a star and he's a
Ralphie's backyard
I'm gardener at six in the [ __ ]
morning you know grilling a [ __ ]
turkey it was it was mind-boggling
you know everybody went to that house I
still remember 9/11 he made a gumball
and we all went to his house and we sat
there we were all disbelief as [ __ ]
there was a couple of arguments and [ __ ]
yeah you know but it was I learned a lot
from him as a comedian yeah
like a lot like my would not only wear
watch to just his demeanor how he was
towards people huh you know I used to
yell at him constantly to get off the
[ __ ] Road man oh man
I stood but he was a he loved it the
time I'm sure she really was and he
would tell you even what he wasn't
feeling good it was our job to get him
up you know and he'd tell us we'd be
sold-out Cleveland or whatever it was
when he hurt his back and then uh he
didn't want to get up so we have six
sold-out shows you need to get up and
then he saw just start 20 minutes late
you [ __ ] titty babies just do
about I don't know about four to five
[ __ ] minutes and then maybe we'll do
intermission I go very noisy listen in a
comedy club [ __ ] get up and he
would tell us that by then once he got
to the club he snapped right into it
smile and you know talking to the
waitresses and he'd go out there and
rock both shows and stand out there with
merch even when he felt like [ __ ] and
that's what we learned from him it
doesn't matter the crowd paid to be
there be [ __ ] funny you know and we
learned a lot from him about that you
know he worked really hard to be funny
like he if you look at his early
specials they're [ __ ] brilliant
oh really are they I forget the ones
name that I [ __ ] love he's just
sensational you know but he all just
correct problems was correct that's of
my time he was by the time he got here
guys he was already a star like in the
making like people knew he got right in
Smits he loved him Jamie Masada loved
him you know he just took right over it
was just a right vehicle to launch and
look what it was it was Last Comic
Standing
yeah come in second place and make a
[ __ ] career out of it I mean he would
always say that he's like I came in
second place and I made a [ __ ] career
out of it you know you didn't have to
win the [ __ ] show he would always say
you know it's what he made America fall
in love with it was
because okay so Last Comic Standing the
results come out and I already have
Houston booked with him it's me him
and he's a Jody fertig or John Wesley
it's the first week of July as something
like that and I'm excited this [ __ ] yeah
I had just I just done nothing let me
tell you what was going on I got a call
I was supposed to shoot spider-man to
July 30th but I got a call like the
first week in June in like July 30th are
you talking about you're gonna get you
ass down here and get the Wardrobe you
shoot next week what are you talking
about I'm gonna [ __ ] tap Houston like
super like just come on down so I went
down the song I got my wardrobe the
whole thing I'm like guys I got booked
to work one day I sign the contract for
one day scale 695 a day everybody
advised me against it everyone's like
you should work for scale [ __ ] them it's
the second one they made millions while
other friend of mine said going in
arguing they're gonna give me the
somebody else watch you just shut your
mouth do the movie it's one line what do
you care yeah well then went down there
that day for Joe I said him and that
watch someone in there like I think he'd
been like typical come with me and they
walked me to this [ __ ] room where the
whole story board was it was
mind-boggling you knowing I'm the
[ __ ] r-rated comic with a cocaine
problem right yeah and Here I am in this
[ __ ] heart room at Sony with the
boards and they said your board starts
here which is yeah next Tuesday and
you're gonna be on 2 August 3rd they go
what are you talking about I got dates
booked this Chanel why are you better
scale it straight now cuz they shot
those train scenes and at the an alley
on 13 14 days for one line Wow because
there was days I had to stand there and
there was days I didn't know first
there are now so make me go to my
[ __ ] thing but the long story short I
got spider-man 2 and I couldn't go down
there with him and had I heard that when
he pulled up in Houston the line was
around the block and people had signed
and they were saying [ __ ] that fan [ __ ]
that fan [ __ ] that fact like it was
[ __ ] crazy at first he created he
went from one thing to another overnight
even though he was a headliner already
like that was what hurt everybody else
on Last Comic Standing over the years
that wasn't a true headliner at the time
that they the one were placed on that
show right you know and so yeah wow he
was already blowing [ __ ] stages up he
already moved up here and that feature
he was headlining in Texas already oh
yeah he was already drawing in Texas
like in Houston he was drawing at Danny
Martinez as he was drawing he was
already drawn at those clubs when he
came up here you know he was like any
other comics struggling but people know
where the [ __ ] he was
and the last comic got him up but then
he just got even stronger yeah with that
winning last comic he [ __ ] did a
complete 180 you know that was his
market though when is wherever his
hometowns were but in outrageous I go we
don't have enough time we can tell you
crazy stories Mike Houston but they've
loved him they're one of the tour bus
pulled in it was on we couldn't sleep on
the tour bus cuz they were banging on
the [ __ ] all night you know cuz
he had this [ __ ] orange jacket on
that first two across the whole side of
the goddamn tour bus is the big biggest
picture of Ralphie you've ever seen in
your [ __ ] life I'm like [ __ ]
they can already see you already and now
you're gonna put a [ __ ] size of a
Ralph's truck sticker on the side of
your [ __ ] bus they're gonna knock on
it on that he's a [ __ ] baby maybe
they'll bring some good drugs to us and
[ __ ] oh my god it ain't all they're
gonna [ __ ] brig to that bus but
they'd knock on it Rock the [ __ ]
you guys sleep on the bus yeah only on
travel but then when we get
the town we would get the hotel or the
condo and so we would you know but he
loved to be on it he'd stay on this town
even though they're banging out he would
just call us girls hey come on here and
get my gun there's people backing on the
bus all right
so we go get the gun - a ak-47 or
whatever week we'd be sitting with
bucket these people don't even know
we're sitting with [ __ ] aks
yeah like [ __ ] that is like a if they
get crazy just let me do the shooting
I'm a millionaire maybe core he's got a
good shot let choreographer shoot he's I
could pay for the Jew lawyers if we kill
anybody but that's how it was you know
but it was that was the thing though
Ralphie when you talk about cooking he
one time we were down for like six days
we're in middle of [ __ ] Nebraska and
he goes hey go to Walmart and and get us
a goddamn barbecue a smoker and get one
of them little chief smokers I'm like
what [ __ ] what do you get a kill a
[ __ ] deer out here what are you gonna
do it he's like oh and stop by the store
and get a bunch of meat and he gave me
this [ __ ] list on January couple
thousand bucks on my we don't need
[ __ ] you know I got a castle yeah we
do baby no get it so we he be smoking
that tooth we'd get down with the shows
he'd smoke all night and we'd eat
breakfast you know 6:00 in the morning
we'd eaten brisket and [ __ ] yeah he'd
cook at night always is that I he loved
all night loved it we'd be listening to
classic rock Vegas Iggy smoking reefer
and he'd wake us up we couldn't hang
with him and then he'd wake of some God
baby we're having brisket for n eggs
wake your ass up that is limit and I'm
not saying the wrong way cuz you know
how I feel about it
yeah that is the most redneck thing in
the world man you know who oh it did
that God was the king of that huh my
mother really cooking a [ __ ] a coarse
meal at 3:00 a.m. and you're [ __ ]
drunk this yeah like I mean when you I
would wake up to like what are you
talking about I just want cereal I just
want cereal rice beans abort cook sliced
thin fried bananas oh [ __ ] like mmm
why'd you cook this I was hungry I'm not
hungry no more you know it [ __ ] like
that
my stepfather the same thing there's
people I don't know anybody who does
that anymore
yeah like when I met Ralphy that was the
first person I know who did that
since I was growing up like when I was
growing up maybe we go to Holloway's
house and he late night but the father
wouldn't get up and cook for us
ya know that [ __ ] no we go to this
awesome raid whatever leftovers we did
that to all the houses yeah for people
that don't know those type of people you
live with him and then you either got
two choices you can either stay up stay
up
yeah I was it with Ralphie our lives
changed instantly we thought we knew
what the comedy business was even like
eight nine years into the game before we
start a tour and hard with them we
thought we knew and then he took us on
to the tour bus we I remember he was
like he called us up who's like a fly to
Chicago and I'm like like we have money
like we have money just the flat of
Chicago you you get to Chicago he's up
and you'll go home in six months you're
gonna go on tour I'm like what the [ __ ]
and I'm like are you [ __ ] and he's
like get to Chicago I got something gone
soon as we got there the [ __ ]
cooking chili and spaghetti
who the [ __ ] makes chili and spaghetti
like yeah Oh cuz he had a full kitchen
you know okay I've never seen Moe okay
his room has it listen the the bus pops
out on the sides but his room has a
California king bed 50-inch TV yeah yeah
a shower
we were teeny not us I mean we're
grateful but we were jerking off in a
casket [ __ ] out of [ __ ] we're
sleeping in the you know the bunks you
know going down the hall this was Dave
Matthews bus so Dave Matthew sold it to
Ralphie
and and it was hooked up I mean has
everything hardwood floors this
[ __ ] has everything yeah there
was a comedian in Austin who had a joke
about it all right yeah the guy who yeah
feature for yeah yeah yeah I remember
him mentioning who you're right but we
would show up and this [ __ ] has
everything and he just was so welcoming
he's like this is your house now put you
back you know this is your house now you
look at us how to make lattes and
espresso because he had a full [ __ ]
Starbucks machine I'm talking like a
five thousand dollar [ __ ] Starbucks
chrome [ __ ] stainless machine I was
making lattes I was professional
[ __ ] within a week as a barista
you know and Ralph that's how he lived
you know he just was so welcoming and if
you got invited not everyone
inviting the bus but if you did you were
family and he just took care of you
that's how he was there's not many
people like that
our mother doesn't even [ __ ] treat us
like that you know but he's a [ __ ] he
was just the greatest when he came to
that [ __ ] but he told me better that
this book this podcast is brought to you
by Vince aro watches tired of choosing
between luxury styling and high-end
quality and an affordable price tag when
Sara watches wants to help you with
timepieces and expertly blend style
timing and class with a price tag
you've never expected a watch built this
well guys when this watch arrived I was
blown away with the quality check out
our shots Lucas this is beautiful there
you understand me do me a favor you're
not just getting to watch elevate your
game elevate your watch game whatever
Sarah watch go to check out Vince Vince
arrow I get the watch net right now
even better than Saros given all church
listeners 15% off their entire purchase
with the promo code Church and check out
it's time to step up your watch game go
to Vince arrow I'd get to watch dot Nets
how you like me now number two let me
tell you something you'd go to Vegas you
gonna Lennox Eddie it's a blast
you get chlamydia the whole thing but
personally I'm a big fan or you know
poker blackjack I like to watch people
play dice sometimes I win sometimes I
lose not so good but I always gave a
good time the problem is getting to
Vegas isn't that easy for me you know
I'm saying I'm a fat [ __ ] woman the roll
escape back and forth but ever since I
found my beat casino betting from the
comfort of my home has been simple and a
[ __ ] blast that's why I always tell
people to go to my be casino dot AG they
got huge bonuses free spins and much
more so off the bat you're already
winning from the day you create your
account do me a favor right join my be
casino and deposit today the triple your
bankroll with their amazing 200% signup
bonus use promo code Church 200 to
activate your offer beat the house from
your
you understand me you said your living
room you got your underwear on you know
your socks your scratching your nuts
you got a sudden urge to gamble he was
Iraqi clean it up the poor [ __ ] drive
around to clean up that [ __ ] that dude
please he was I know he made more than
everybody let's the driver made more
than us I was like what what movie is
that Oh
Scarface when he makes himself a fool
the restaurant huh and The Bodyguard
first man's a guy money and then he
thinks about it for a second he gives
more money without the NDC's Alize
coughing laughter he says I might as
well this guy's mega-mega yeah poor poor
guy that guy but he was a good guy okay
better I'll feel he loved him and he was
a real good guy took care of us in every
way possible I probably could even tell
you about right now but anything we
needed he took care of it so he's a good
guy what did you learn comedy wise from
what you said before that you know let's
cool this show and joke joke structure
and and and the one thing that he with
being a duo he would he broke it down to
where and us being identical twins and
like even in high school and in college
we took theater arts we took anything we
didn't have homework so home AK we were
in there yeah woodshop anything that we
knew they weren't gonna sign homework
that's what the [ __ ] we took but we
learned but the joke structure he broke
it down by telling us he was like when
they watch you you know and he was
critiquing us about either stepping on
each other's lines talking over each
other
tone of voice he hated our beards he
kept telling us to shave all the time
what we wore the hole he broke us down
like if he were [ __ ] Simon Cowell and
he literally just broke us down every
day and and he told us to he said you
know he doesn't even have to listen to
what we're saying he said I listen to
the crowd laugh it's like a roller
coaster he goes you guys got him and
then it's quiet and then you got him and
you got him you got him and you know and
then you and it's down again he goes he
goes I just know you did good I don't
know what the [ __ ] he talked about but I
can know by listening to the crowd how
you he said last per minute he always
[ __ ] with us you know you need more laps
per minute
harder and that's when you tell us he
goes I don't need to listen to you no
more I just listened to the last it's
crazy
I've been doing comedy for 27 years I
don't need to watch it yeah I could hear
you from the green room
yeah listen until your audience really
you're listening and sometimes I could
get up I'm a [ __ ] comic yeah I have
to listen the ears are the most
important gift when you're a comic if
you don't [ __ ] listen you'll never
move on that's gonna help you with a
one-man show
that's gonna help you with acting that's
gonna help you with a thousand things in
your life is listening listening to the
I'm [ __ ] deaf because when I'm on
stage my ears work so [ __ ] hard I
want to hear the [ __ ] I want to hear
you staring the glass yeah you
understand me it's like you develop the
spider sense after 20 years it takes
about 20 to 22 years you know where you
devout look at lately if I got twenty
two years it goes by like 15 years how
fast does it go it feels like we're just
doing one minute you would do it open
mics the next me around Terry oh one
Wednesday a month amassment you sound
not a [ __ ] place yeah and next minute
you're on the road with Ralphie [ __ ]
man learning the education of life yeah
a life within a bus a guy with money how
he acts
hi handling post time you know post time
means listen I do I I didn't even sleep
last night and then have six to [ __ ]
chick came over we didn't [ __ ] point
our baggage we [ __ ] til 10 then I took
a nap then I got up and Johnny Benihana
came over and made some steaks for us I
did another nine and now they wake you
up at 7:15 going show times at 8:00 what
do you want me to deal with man you you
get up you're 500 [ __ ] pounds half
you [ __ ] can't get up after
that yeah this 500-pound mammoth man
would pick those fat little legs up sit
on the edge of that bed for five minutes
yeah and that listen you're talking to a
400-pound dude
time you just get fired up then you
think about your childhood and you think
about your past and where you've been
and how come you're selling out the
Ontario [ __ ] improv but there's not a
picture you were no [ __ ] in progress
yeah you did that [ __ ] I know you rip
somebody's picked him down he would
think of that now that's what a real
comic does you know a couple weeks ago
Rogan was talking to people and on a
podcast and he goes look at the end I
figured out this after a while the ass
do not listen to what he says to you
before you go onstage especially if he
picks a fight with you he's darling to
pick a fight with you he's done arguing
you he's dying for you to have the wrong
shirt or the wrong pair of shoes because
he's not [ __ ] with you he's flying
himself up together on stage that I saw
him do that one night I said we were in
New York and Cattleman's and I when I
woke him up he would you know I mean
let's be honest dear people he didn't
become 500 pounds because he got up and
jogged on the morning all right
he landed in New York at 2:00 in the
afternoon he got to the [ __ ] room at
3:00 I got to the room at 4:30 the tray
of chocolate and this gorgeous Manhattan
hotel which was 9,000 a night was done
all the rappers were in the garbage
that's a sugar high like a coke fiend
doing an eight ball of coke and then
that Sabbath he would [ __ ] you know
those up with his glasses or [ __ ] them
yeah and he would get up and it was post
time yeah and then you'd see him 20
minutes later and he was up there like a
ballerina
Oh as graceful as compete you know I'm
saying then later when I'm he gotta
start sitting guys yeah yes yeah I
started sitting and then he's leaning up
we started noticing to even in the past
couple years he would start out standing
and then he'd sit for the last glass bit
you know the last hour he would sit and
then he'd stand up to close you know and
we started noticing that's funny you
said that we've noticed that he went
from standing the whole two hours to
what setting a lot gentlemen I try to go
to jujitsu a week
I got kettlebells in my backyard I have
a punching bag
I really stay active that's good when I
started comedy even after The Longest
Yard I was never a headlight I was a
feature and they had wanted me because I
had been in a movie and whatnot
after I saw those people in 2009 my hand
had to change you know like somebody
once said to me don't cuddle me three
years I was a headline but I told
somebody and they're only listen
comedies like pens oh you're gonna pay
me now or you could pay me later you
gotta put the [ __ ] timing yeah you
know and what we're talking about
putting time in for comedy you know you
gotta put the [ __ ] time admit yeah
it's not overnight like you said no look
look at how fortunate you guys hmm I
mean if anything anything someday as
I'll be telling your children and your
grandchildren these stories and you got
to work with the greatest comedian song
of our time you know they'd be ranked 10
top comics he's gotta be in there that's
powerful pop I mean
comedian wise I don't care whether you
like them I don't care whether you like
this tie I don't care whether you like
that he didn't like cuz he said the word
[ __ ] on stage yeah I don't I know you
gotta love disagreement for them but I'm
telling you as a fellow comic when you
read the comedy 101 book he was in there
he was in there he used the pattern he
was a true professional which my by me
watching him help me become the headline
now today I'm a hella [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
yeah I'm saying yeah 20 years ago when I
thought I was a headliner cuz The Improv
and all the funny bones headlined you
that doesn't make you a headline now
there's a point where you find out
you're a headline yeah when you you know
you're like Jesus Christ I have a
different influence over them now
right this is where and that's when you
can't believe it like I started going to
the fourth wall in North Hollywood it's
five minutes for five hours feeling Joey
do that stupid it's because it's like
going back to when you started then are
you sitting with kids that had the same
dream we had when you sat in front of
Last Comic Standing yeah how did you
guys feel sitting in front of a building
and for The Last Comic Standing why did
you go that way
we were watching headliners just to beat
we got humble back so we were like three
years into it at that time
three four years and we we had a hot 20
minutes at best and maybe even 12 and a
half minutes and we thought we had
enough time I remember we did a set at
the Melrose improv and we were leaving
there and I told my brother I go
remember the auditions are 7:00 a.m.
Monday and I go we should be bad
[ __ ] and just stay right here
and he was like stay right here right
now a member we debated it out that
whole night and then Chad called the
hotel down the street and we got a room
for the next three nights the hostel a
hostel and we we would swap in and
that's a hungry work we wanted to do it
just to see if we would get on the show
first of all but second of all we did it
to try to go to the next [ __ ] level
but we didn't realize we weren't ready
you don't know until you know we just
weren't ready and what comedians were
coming by and I remember different
people were like what the [ __ ] are you
guys doing out here you know for like
two nights we were there only people in
line people didn't start getting in line
until Saturday night when they saw that
[ __ ] homeless were standing behind us
thinking it's a soup kitchen waiting for
a [ __ ] free bowl of soup you know
everyone was just standing line you
didn't know what you were standing the
line just went down the [ __ ] all the
way down to the 101 almost you know it
was a [ __ ] line for Last Comic
Standing in that second thirty but you
know we didn't we didn't get the show
and this is this is true [ __ ] Joey
[ __ ] we get kicked off last Comic
Standing we start walking down Melrose
this car pulls up and says are you twins
I said go [ __ ] your son we're pissed be
sent for four [ __ ] days
go [ __ ] yourself no listen if you're
twins I'm a producer would you like to
do a TV show so he hands us his card I
don't call him I'm [ __ ] pissed that I
sat down the street for four [ __ ]
days I call him that Monday come on down
we don't we know what show we're on
we're just on a TV show we find out
we're on that show are you smarter than
fifth grader with Jeff Oxford we had no
[ __ ] ideas before I was even before I
wasn't even on TV it was just a [ __ ]
like a pilot was just something that
they were filming well skip ahead we got
a hundred seventy five grand off that
show so we got kicked off last Comic
Standing and then we got that so as it
worked out Ralphie told us he's like
listen don't be [ __ ] idiots
and you know we only knew him for a
couple years at this point he goes you
take that money and you invest it into
your comedy buy t-shirts and go on the
road and do pizza place anywhere little
[ __ ] have even if you lose money you
have money and go grab all the win him
around so whatever town we'd run into
him on purpose and he'd let us open that
was our whole plan were like oh Ralph
he's in [ __ ] Detroit we need to show
up at Detroit and we would just drive
our Nissan Altima wherever the [ __ ] we
needed to go and we do gigs at [ __ ]
karaoke whatever and that's what we
would do and that's how we spent that
money most people would blow it we spent
it on [ __ ] going around trying to
develop a headline act you know and it
took well more than ten years for us
well more than ten years to get an hour
I mean last night we did it out we did a
show with you and we did an hour and 15
for a bunch of drug addicts was the
greatest night we had a great time but
it took us that long because a Ralphie
helped us get there we wouldn't have
done it we'd have blown our money I
would have bought drugs and [ __ ]
guaran-fucking-tee
and Ralphie's all know go on the road
and that's what we did I mean who gives
you advice like that and what our
friends will tell us go buy blow no I
don't tell you when you tweet me because
but now people know the situation I
don't go see you guys as much as I want
to because eh yeah I do the punt kiss on
Wednesday Sun yeah but B I have a [ __ ]
up here they get carsick oh I mean last
weekend with this shoot I'm dying up and
I got there with puke on my shirt and
puke on the collar on the 405
it's getting worse I'm having a little
imprint put in and then I'll be down
there you guys wanna a great dirty show
yeah in Ontario for [ __ ] ten years
twelve years ago he is went down there
twice you gave away dildos yep
you gave me mad money he got me high but
there was chicks showing her tits I know
it's [ __ ] insanity down there it's -
have you ever got a chance I mean I'm
not wrapping up much I'm just trying to
tell people that and I talk about it all
the time this is a tonight's a comedian
podcast
it's the struggle and we're also
honoring our good dear friend a little
bit was a I don't know how old he would
have been yesterday for my have been 46
46 that's when I thought so it's just
let me give some shout out to him
alright I want to [ __ ] shout out Rick
Atkins Kris Cobain or Jake eager brine
Stiles Leticia Kaden my med bobble
Lingus and thank you for the dr. J
original picture G tweets Adam house
Mason Schroder I love all you
[ __ ] I love my man Bobby link
as always I called him last week we
talked a little while sharp dude I'm
mrs. daddy mrs. and dad were [ __ ]
family so that's that no I'm happy that
uh I got to sit with you and do a show
last night yeah that's fun you know
you're always welcome to come on here
you guys are real [ __ ] down
last night you gave me some great news
so after 12 years of selling out they
finally gave you some tour dates this
[ __ ] like that yeah they said you guys
are getting started what's that what
what's the web page they can find you so
identical entertainments our company but
you can just find us on all social media
Cory and Chad cor why the letter n CH ad
you find us on that and we post all of
our gigs you know though it's the
education that a real comic thin flakes
are cuz I I love young comics yeah I
love young Thomas but you know who's
faking the funk and I knows really doing
what they're doing by the look in their
eye that's why I went back to the fourth
wall like I said it's like Rocky III but
Apollo took them back to the ghetto yeah
they have a gym with music and I were
saying is you should Apollo's like what
do you know it we're going back to the
ghetto look at their eyes that's what
your eyes used to look like 12 years ago
sure you know I went on the road for a
while I just got this chanted it's all
about ticket sales it's not
you know you just want you can light a
stick about listen you know here with
guys like us worked for 20 years they
won't give us a headline week and some
guy goes up there takes a butane tank
blow smoke and possessed and boy he's
selling out yeah and we got our feelings
hurt because we realize it's all about
ticket sales it's all about ticket sales
when you're selling tickets they love
you when you're not and it's amazing to
go through that education and to see
Ralphie hello Ralph I went you know I
saw Ralphie when the beams the big fat
guy in Beaumont Texas and let's go see
him you know yeah but it turns into
something [ __ ] else like the theatres
and stuff and just watching that will
stay with you guys for it's an education
oh we learned a lot and what you do in a
club I mean you'll learn this what you
do in a club you're not doing in a
theater yeah you know the theater show
is completely different than a club and
we learned that like real [ __ ] oh
yeah I'm gonna take them up to the
Wilbur leather month oh yeah in the
[ __ ] Boston crowd yeah he'll detonate
by 20 he'll start going at the Boston
when I lived in Boston they went over
it's crazy how you really it's a
psychological like I'm looking at now
like I can't believe I survived 25 years
like you guys drive home go oh what the
[ __ ] was just what the [ __ ] we do that
all the time like when we cuz it's been
awhile since we've worked with you and
we were leaving you know that the
Icehouse driving down to the NAA show we
were doing I told Chad I go man it's a
big difference between you know years
ago working with you and now it's like
and the friendship and bond and I
remember we used to do shows with you
like crazy [ __ ] bar show bar no Liam
we remember we yeah we've done a lot of
[ __ ] with 909 there Tuesday night yes
anyway they always gave me like 128
dollars yeah yeah you never gave me the
115 just give me the 115 I'm beggin
either you pay 128 by 128 we've taken a
totally tool out of commission don't
give me some buffalo wings will give you
a kiss you know I never forget that you
never forget that you never forget
illicitly those are the things that
those are the things that you'll sit
there with named your office and you
sitting there looking at your big
chisels anyway [ __ ]
yeah you know you here is a $65 no yeah
we have a list of movie just this is it
and at the time it seemed so big because
it's gonna understand that it's 75
dollars and I need 60 for the read yeah
and if I give the drug dealer 15 he
might give me a quarter grand like
definitely you know people don't
understand when you go to a gig and I'm
gonna hop out you ever go to a gig and
you need the cash and somebody throws it
right at you yes oh yeah we got [ __ ]
in Tucson we needed it
oh we need it and they give us a check
we look down we go you better come up
with some cash luckily uh
somehow we got a tip from a [ __ ] [ __ ]
a fan on The Late Show [ __ ] fan gave
us each $100 bill that's one way we got
home you know we had a [ __ ] check and
a fangames 100 our built-in is like I've
never seen guys like you here's 100
bucks and we looked at exert our -
crying we couldn't believe it we're
gonna get we're gonna get [ __ ] some
weed some beer and drive home now
that's maybe some [ __ ] cracker barrel
or something oh yeah back off a house we
needed it bad you gotta be dates coming
up next weekend we're in Sacramento
February you know 23rd to the 25th we're
at laughs unlimited next Wednesday
Ontario improv
we're in zannies April 24th Terios
already sold out it is
but there might be a couple but it's
always sold out it's already sold
Janey's in Nashville in April the 21st
and 22nd and just sporadic ones we start
picking up steam and we're back in
Pittsburgh you know in the summer you
know they're redoing the Pittsburgh
improv as soon as it's done we're back
there so we're just glad we're finally
getting [ __ ] gage you know I wanted to
bring you the show
apologize to both of you personally for
not attending the Ralphie May memorial I
need to apologize to you guys as men
that I had a reasoning why I uh
yeah I do hold grudges and he was a big
mentor to me as a brother and you know
everything he was to you guys ya know
and no I just wanted to be like this I
wanted to be southern style I wanted to
be Hollywood style
I just once I heard the attendees of
what had happened now and what happened
the day afterwards I was sick to my
stomach
but the only person I felt they had to
apologize to or do you - I know how much
you loved them and I know when you heard
the news your boat shattered for days
and you'll be shattered for years
I stood not erased his phone oh yeah I
got the greatest but I haven't deleted
his number not one you know meaning that
I won't either so uh I want to thank
yous both thank you for joining me and
we will always work together on February
17th okay yeah whatever day it falls on
you and I will always do a show okay
even if it's broke in New Jersey yeah
well neither was show together I will be
dead it is sold out but I will be in
Huntsville Alabama stand up March 1st to
a third and then I'll be at Nyack New
York that what's they let me live March
21st at 8 p.m. I want to thank Cory Chad
for coming back on again and for being
the [ __ ] that y'all I want to
thank those two guys I like those two
[ __ ] savages I always have they've
done a great job
with the dirty show but let's change the
subject real quick let me talk to you
people but some I got a thousand watches
at the house I got a call one day from
marketing lady and she goes uh take over
the Pistons Sara watches we had watches
before and I didn't like them they
didn't sell right nobody who even went
to the thing I thought they were more
expensive than what the ads so I always
look at stuff before I send the telly
and they'll say yeah and maybe now you
know I looked at this pretty Sara
watches I was like you know what there's
something here a couple days later I get
one in the mail I get two of them in the
mail a gold-plated one like a
silver-plated one to put them on and I
put a jacket on that night and I put the
watch I just loved how it looked so on
this one here this is a white on silver
I'm gonna shove a camera here they can
see there's a beautiful little white on
silver pattern you got the two clocks in
there I mean unless the guys when it
arrived I was blown away I was and when
I looked at the prices and I looked at
what I had on that's what really blew me
away I mean they feel great on the wrist
and honestly I received a lot of
compliments too beautiful watch I'm
telling you on the silver one that I
have on right now
a few more zeros attest to the price so
it's a bit depressing but guys if you're
in the market for a great watch I like
direct your attention to a sweet piece
on my wrist I absolutely love them in
cero Vince arrow is a dope brand because
they make watches that look and feel
luxurious while still giving you outfit
that distinct unique look and you know
I'm not you know I'm not into outfits
but it ensures you a compliment but
people say I like that Joey your wrist
looks good when your buddies are wearing
their little Apple watches you'll be
like millions more on bang
look at my vince arrow like a savage
like I said I'm wearing a simple t-shirt
and I put a nice massero watch on and I
was like rocky to that that's just the
way it is I picked up this beautiful
silver one with their with this uh metal
band and I gotten a lot like I said even
my wife says it looks good
but personal favorite is this one the
white with the black or the white on
this the silver but I also like the gold
trim also with the same style I don't
know the name of this style so don't be
mad at me right now watches like these
they go for 500 for small nickel but
we've been cero they started a hundred
and fifty dollars are you kidding me or
what don't take our word for it they got
sixty five hundred five star reviews
alright listen do me a favor just get
the watch elevate your watch game right
now
you want a sling dick this is how you do
it you want to walk into a bar and
people say that's an important man get
up in cero watch go check out Vince
arrow and get to watch dotnet right now
go look at these wines imma I'm not
breaking your chance for a buck and a
half these watches are phenomenal the
heavy they feel solid on your wrist even
better then Sarah's given all church the
family 15% off your entire purchase with
promo code Church at checkout listen
come on knock it off with that little
dirty watching Ilana it's time to step
up your watch game go check with Sarah
and get the watch dotnet again Vince
arrow I get the watch dotnet I like that
look on your face Lee
it's a look at I'm going deep tonight
forget about it don't worry about
nothing there you go people well I know
people like going to Vegas to Atlantic
City could be a blast you go to a strip
club get you something get sucked but
personally I'm a big fan I like watching
people play blackjack and poke and stuff
like that sometimes I win you know me
I'm a monster though I can like I'm I
got Ali with me he can't
this poor kid he'll play me feel you're
the kiss of death sometimes I win but
not so much but I always got a good time
the problem is getting the Vegas ain't
got time to get the meal to go to Vegas
ain't easy for me I got a wife I got a
kid but ever since I found my B casino
betting from the comfort of my casa
there has been simple and a blast that's
why I tell people to go to my B casino
not a G they got huge bonuses free spins
and a lot more
so off the bat you're already winning
from day one you create the account and
best of all when you get your big win
you get paid it's that fast Elise that's
all most important thing I can sit there
all day we can go back and vote playing
cards well if you're gonna hit me with a
[ __ ] IOU what good is it you just
wasted 12 of my hours I could have been
mugging a Shriner or something no no
more whether you like blackjack roulette
slots or any other game my be casino as
a lolly you don't have to deal with
Chinese people breathing on your neck no
more plus if you want real Vegas
experience they also have live dealers
online where's the last time you saw my
deal online that book I've been on a
couple times and actually pretty hot to
follow what I'm saying to me I would
recommend a website to my listeners
that's been good to me and that's why
I'm urging you to make your way there
might be casino you win you party they
pay are you [ __ ] kidding me or what
you sucked up to Valentine's Day this
college basket of things but now you can
make some quick money join my be casino
and deposit today to your triple
bankroll triple your bankroll with their
amazing 200% signup bonus two hundred
percent right now you can sign up
playing cards tonight have a good time
buy yourself a wife don't need to bother
nobody later on you do a couple blasts
your bang one out after you're up a
hundred two listen go to my big casino
right now and deposit the triple your
bankroll alright use promo code Church
200 BAM
to activate the offer beat the house
from the house with slippers only your
balls hanging scratching sniffing your
fingers play my be casino dot AG today
use promo code Church 200 you win you
play you get [ __ ] paid and it's sooo
coming time alright I love you guys
happy birthday to me I love you
[ __ ] my family I'll be back in
Wednesday and then me and Lisa I'll be
[ __ ] parachuting our way into them of
the [ __ ] six quick shows bring reefer
bring edibles bring grenades
mushrooms bring whatever the [ __ ] you
got you in this damn it we're going deep
deep deep into the murky waters in the
end or then the week after that the
helicopters gonna drop me off right
there in Huntsville we're taking over
[ __ ] Huntsville for [ __ ] five show
store either yeah and you have I don't
get this and I don't go down there that
deep so if you want to if you're
wonderful know small neighborhoods get
on the mule right now you'll make it
there by March first as I ain't coming
back though [ __ ] Atlanta next year so
I switch it around so if you live in
Atlanta get on that [ __ ] car and
drive the tree house [ __ ] I'll
see you guys next week I want to thank
my brothers Corey and Chad at Corey and
Chad they're [ __ ] everywhere they're
savages I want to thank my Jewish
[ __ ] over here Lisa at stay
black have a great Monday [ __ ] it